so the new show Lopez versus Lopez is
based on your lives right yeah it's
Loosely based is that hard you know what
I'm not going to say blue screen I'm the
one that did all that that was wrong
I know but I'm just saying is that hard
like to like I don't know like it's hard
for me sometimes I write a lot about my
real life and songs right it's hard for
me to like rehash that yeah I would have
to say there are times where it is
challenging but where I like to think is
that this is such an opportunity to heal
and I've always wanted my pain to mean
something and yeah you know as you've
done like to reach out and carry much as
people and know that healing isn't
linear but you're not perfect and you
know just having empathy you know as you
get older you start to see your parents
as people and yeah you know maybe you
understand some things you don't have to
forgive them but you can understand and
you know going backwards and healing but
also rebuilding something stronger for
the future they're very healthy I'm very
therapy everyone's like where have you
been I'm like therapy I was like wow I
would say that
I would say that that message probably
conveyed a bit much better in song it
sounds better somebody's saying you were
never there for me as opposed to you're
never
there no if you lighten it with a nice
Melancholy Melody yes yes exactly but
it's good though that you all have that
communicative I wish I would have had
that like my father passed away so we
never got that and I tried so hard a lot
of people really want that and desire
that and don't get that so it's really
remarkable and awesome but we believe
you know the first show had a different
slide you know this is fathers and
daughters and that relationship is worth
you know preserving and trying to get
back if there's fathers out there not
speaking to their daughters
um you know I I when I was growing up
was very tough and people would just
disappear from your lives yeah and uh I
finally realized that as an adult that I
couldn't and didn't want to do that or
go down that road anymore and that this
person right here was the one love of my
life and then the one I would never let
go for for anything so I would uh
[Applause]
[Music]
guys I'm going home